au 4ème licence graphique je veux dire
par là grave très bien oui c'est très
bien mais ils ont une difficulté quand
même
ouais j'en du mal l'a5 à la de l'argent
mais quand même on a des idées plus
d'idées que d'argent je peux dire qu'il
ya vachement l'information incroyable
surtout vous avez des informations
spécialement 5,6 gens c'est vrai c'est
quand icade a trié en direct et tout ça
c'est quand même extraordinaire quand je
débrouille moi je trouve que les
informations sont super ennuyeuse et
machin c'est le seul que je trouve pas
moi qui se forment un personnage
médiatique c'était de poids c'est
spécial quand même du mal duhamel
non c'est vrai cccc particulièrement la
france là c'est celle ci c'est une bonne
idée vous êtes bien moi j'aime bien de
valeur maintenant dit lundi qu'il
pêchait à écouter vous ne pourrez la
tête la chair pour n'être pas la
question je réponds pas à la question
qui t'a posé mon garçon